women's soccer team they lost and
everybody's making fun of Megan Rapinoe
for missing what is considered to be a
very easy penalty kick costing the US
the match they've been eliminated and
you know I feel like for most people
most people who are who are into
politics and culture if this individual
was if Megan rapid knows like a nice
humble person we have someone's audience
blasting if Megan rapping I was a good
person that people really liked we'd all
be like nah it's cool you missed this
shot but we got your back thank you for
everything you do but but she's
insufferable she's got this viral video
where she screams I deserve this over
and over again she's got this video
people are dragging her where someone
this little this little kid wants a
signature on a soccer ball and she just
like Signs it and doesn't even look at
him just passes it off like he's not
even there and so she's a nasty person
Trump roaster saying nice shot Megan
blaming Joe Biden and wokeness for the
loss and this is the US losing on the
international stage not the biggest
story in the world but culturally
relevant because it's a component of get
well go broke